what i did find out
um is in these conversations
i can keep on trying to educate or
convince or sell write to someone and
it's just the message doesn't get
through
but when the customer has the needs that
i'm talking about
it is crystal clear like that's a
customer that usually does not need any
explanation
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we
are back in the cloud with mati lerna
the co-founder and ceo of ridge
mati is co-founder and ceo at ridge the
world's most distributed public cloud
mati invests and advises early stage
companies and he has an mba from london
business school
mate lerner welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm really excited to have you here
thank you so much for joining me how are
you
that we're excited to be here uh
hopefully we'll have a good uh good talk
i'm sure we will because pretty much
everybody's in the cloud and if they're
not in the cloud then they're thinking
about the cloud and if they're not
thinking about the cloud then they
really should be thinking about the
cloud and so we're at a really
interesting inflection point where we
have all these solutions and we have
this technology we understand the
potential we sort of understand the
deployment and we understand how to
manage it but now we're in the process
of actually making it happen and so with
with ridge
you're doing some really interesting
things that are they're non-trivial in
relation to to the cloud and so i'm
really looking forward to you know
hearing your personal perspective on
this industry what you're personally
doing with ridge and what excites you
about it so so thank you for spending
these 20 minutes with me
tell me a little bit about
cloud computing from your perspective
even before ridge where where are we at
i mean
i think we're at um a place that
you know to us is
you know people who are around startups
and are kind of digital and modern
cloud is a no-brainer it's a total
commodity today
you know the majority of people we
interact with in a day-to-day don't
think about things you know that used to
be called i.t
you know it's uh it magically happens uh
when in fact i t and cloud is just a
form of i.t you just consume it on
someone else's resources
is a huge hassle
i think the beauty it's a massive asset
right and it's uh kind of the
underlining of every single company in
the world digital or not digital it has
massive i.t operation under it
and things that you know used to
you know just give you an example when i
started my career i was at 888 in israel
the first floor i don't know 150 people
only dealt with i.t for a mid-sized
company it's not even a big company
globally
um
you know and what cloud did is changed
that right so essentially you can
consume all of the it best in breed on
demand scalable secure
performant without the need of dealing
with something that is external to your
business you know ideas in the same way
that you know a company doesn't build
its own building you outsource it to a
constructor um
the idea is i shouldn't be dealing with
the physical servers and the connections
and the
gateways and the load balancers because
maybe there's uh someone that in a
centralized way can fix it
so
while we as kind of a cloud native
generation
think about cloud as mostly the only
thing
um the reality is that 85 percent of the
it in the world is still consumed
outside of a public cloud public cloud
to me being aws gcp microsoft azure
and a long tail of other providers that
are also quite big uh
digital ocean ibm oracle cloud there's
quite a few that all of them making the
few billions a year is in revenue but
definitely there's three main players in
the market so 85 is the consumed outside
of a public cloud and
there's all these companies that are
working super hard on it and there's
many reasons why that's the case it
might be because of
mostly technical difficulties
so legacy applications you go to siemens
bosch and all those companies i mean
they have real requirements they have 40
50 years of id spent in whatever they're
doing and just they can just take
everything and chuck it onto a public
cloud
um there might be regulatory
considerations so data locality the
residency that are very very specific
there's uh performance issues like
sometimes you need your servers to be
very close to wherever you're doing the
um you know wherever the application is
deployed that you know close to your
customers close to work data's being
generated um and while the big
hyperscalers are again phenomenal
they're quote unquote only in 20 odd
locations around the world
best locations but only 20 while the
world is slightly bigger than 20
locations
so
what ridge does
right what what is the problem that
we're trying to solve if you take uh you
know those three facts that i just
mentioned
majority of it vast majority of i.t
consumed outside of public uh the
hyperscale at the public cloud
um
kind of the second
underpinning of this is that the world
is moving to cloud native while perhaps
you
you're not considering it on a public
cloud you still want to have all the
good stuff that comes with a public
cloud um
you know cicd pipelines devop tools you
know fancy logging elasticity pain on
demand you know all of those things that
you know come with the public you want
someone else to take care of the
underlying i.t
um
and the third fact is there isn't an
easy way to consume
resources cloud natively
outside of a public cloud and what
region's done it's created a full stack
of full cloud
operator that is agnostic to the
underlying physics of where it runs
right so what it means is that we're
able essentially and this is the core
technology that we built with a lot of
capabilities and features but the core
technology is that we're able to overlay
the reach cloud that looks and feels a
lot like
gcp aws azure um on top of anything that
any customer might have and that goes in
two ways we can take private instances
again as i said we can go to a bosch
icms right like a multinational that has
ip environments scattered all over the
world an overlay solution
without installing anything without you
know making them buy specific hardware
with you know just through very fancy
api and a lot of capabilities on our
side and have them a private and private
instance that looks like a public cloud
the other thing that we've done for
cloud native companies right so if
you're a startup you'd say like i don't
have any servers because i don't think
that way i'm working on aws
but i need to be in
istanbul for whatever reason or in the
uae or in
brazil or like in many places where
perhaps aws is not enough investors if
azure are not enough so in that case
what we've done is we've partnered with
hundreds of different providers local
providers so those would be the top tier
providers for each market so you think
from anyone from like the equinixes of
the world like the biggest
infrastructure providers you know the
entities the deutsche telecoms down to a
local provider in a specific country
where perhaps a global player is in
but still very good kind of high
reliability in most cases even higher
than the public cloud because they host
the local banks the local insurance
centers the local government
so essentially we also created all these
partnerships that allow us to serve our
cloud in a modern cloud way where you
can pay by the minute on demand
um yeah that's about it
so if first of all it sounds it sounds
really interesting because one thing one
trend that you're describing here is
taking the very generalistic approach
that says
let's create a solution that with a
click of a button you can deploy however
many resources that are you know
independently scalable and have pretty
much no limits on this public color and
you're saying wait but but actually you
know the way that a lot of problems are
built is that you need this granular
approach where you need to to have
control and you need to have preferences
over the location over the different
types over the different activities that
are happening there and so you're taking
the generalistic technology or the the
new consumer behavior that we've adopted
which is the general public cloud but
you're assimilating it to
specific nuances the different companies
like like these large companies that you
mentioned that they have themselves did
i get that right you're exactly correct
so you know flexibility is a key point
here um
again aws gcp and azure are phenomenal
for many reasons but that they cater for
the
80 that are good to come to them and if
there's anything specific it's great but
it's not what they can solve um and
that's where we try so you know in fact
public clouds are we're we're riding the
tailwinds of public clouds they're
creating all this massive cloud adoption
right
and you know
100 of the customers that are using
bridge
also use
a hyperscaler right no one will move to
cloud because of reach what they're
saying is like
hey like the public cloud is phenomenal
but i need it to do more than it
currently does
how can i do that without kind of
re-engineering or reinventing the world
and reaches that easy way of doing that
i love it so essentially you're saying
you know we understand that there's this
market education that's been happening
over the last few years we've understood
that there's a big gap here in the
market that while they're catering to 80
percent of you know of the providers
there is a tale of those that need this
specific granular approach and we are
able to provide them the solution but
but take me now to sort of this you know
this moment where you're working with
this executive from from a large company
that you you know you realize that they
have this need they share with you their
you know their different specific needs
that that it happens to be that ridge
you know
perfectly answers them
now they it sounds like they need to
decide between ridges startup and using
one of the three top providers that you
mentioned
and you know this is talking about their
you know their their uptime it's talking
about their reliability about their
deployment how do you deal with that
conflict of of trust and experience
great question so i have two answers to
that uh
you know our sales team does
qualification calls with you know a
devops team any the first question is
like hey are you guys using the cloud
usually the answer is yes
who are you using let's say one of the
big providers like do you have any needs
that are not being met
all the stuff that we just spoke about
before and if the answer is no we're
kind of happy then you say it's like
good then like you're not our customer
right so the point what i'm trying the
point that i'm trying to make is like
we're not competing with them we're not
trying to take us or not because we i i
like i wouldn't wanna it's just because
those are great offerings but as i said
um put it in just in numbers right the
id market is over a trillion dollars
worth of spend per year
okay
aws gcp and azure combined
depends on how you measure it's quite
complicated to to measure that but there
are about 150 billion in revenue growing
like crazy but 150 so that's 15 or less
than what the world spends on id and
when i say i think i mean
telcos banks you know insurance connect
healthcare providers people that are not
usually or not deeply into aws gcp and
azure
any and there's a correlation between
size
and
complexity
right if you're a 20 person startup
usually your application is just limited
in its complexity i'm putting aside the
edge cases of someone doing for
something super super complicated uh id
wise
um
the second thing is that a lot of our
big interactions don't happen directly
right so as you mentioned we are about
three years
old we're i don't know 40 50 people with
growing we kind of want to double this
this year but at the end of the day it's
still tiny compared to big-ip players so
think of anyone like vmware ca
you know like the biggest kind of
companies in the world so what we do is
we need a partner with those so these
guys have massive problems that they
cannot answer around
measures not niches but particular use
cases of what our
system is capable of doing distributed
cloud edge cloud those things they don't
really
have a good solution to
and probably more interesting is the
biggest solution and integrators in the
world so the si is what they're calling
the it industry if you think of you know
the accentures infosys
cognizant kindred that was just fun out
of um ibm um we were kind of quite close
to and looking into some
fascinating technological projects all
of them have you know 75 each one of
them separately inserting about 75 of
the fortune 500 type companies and the
equivalent in every local market um
trying to answer these crazy use cases
without the tools so there isn't a true
competitor to what we do i.t is
complicated and there's many ways of
doing the same thing you can brute force
a lot of the problems
but you know the truth is that like the
world was operating quite well before
public cloud was invented you know so
can things be done yes but they cannot
be done easily and this is i think like
the 10x of where we take ip environments
into a cloud era with the simplicity of
a public cloud without the need to rip
out everything you've got and install
everything from scratch so
um
it's kind of i tried to establish before
we're not exactly
playing for the same market as uh an aws
region would
there aren't great
ways of solving the scent that what i'm
describing here right so these guys are
saying hey we're dealing with these kind
of problems
this is insane and we're at the
beginning of this wave right like
there's a lot of education a lot of
conversations that we need to do for a
million technological reasons that we
need to kind of
the other side says listen this is what
i've been dreaming about i have a few
problems on my side to adopt this you
know i'm not ready my i'm not
containerized i'm not this i'm not that
but i think in the next five years which
is like infrastructure companies look at
things a little bit differently than
perhaps you know a classic sas company
would right like adoption-wise um i
think there's going to be a massive um
take in the next five years of these
capabilities
so then you know talking a little bit
about scale and growth if we're looking
at a more granular approach and those
that need
a different offering than what a
you know a self-serve product may be
able to give them at this point
then how how do you strategically grow
ridge with customer base that that kind
of needs guidance and needs you know the
a little bit more of the hand-holding
approach to tailor the exact solution
for their specific needs which sometimes
may not be
that coherent when you just talk to them
great question i'll start from the last
comment so
it was totally not coherent for us for
the first you know a year and a half
we're still building again as you can
imagine is quite a heavy undertaking to
build this product
um so it took a while to kind of
put it in a place that it can work in
production with like again big-scale
company large-scale companies working in
production um
so um
what i did find out
um is in these conversations
i can keep on trying to educate or
convince or sell right to someone and
it's just the message doesn't get
through
but when the customer has the needs that
i'm talking about
it is crystal clear like that's a
customer that usually does not need any
explanation he's just because he's
experiencing it himself and
and it's like super clear to them what
we do and like now now it's details can
you how do you connect the network how
do you do that how do you do the app
like it's it's so let's kind of just
start from the
last bit of the question
i think
again the other thing that we found out
is the traditional also companies feel
comfortable buying from who they've been
buying before so it's precisely not a
self-serve
three clicks optimizing for quick
onboarding like we are unfortunately in
a world of heavy enterprise sales
through big resellers and big uh um kind
of uh so it's not middlemen but like
engineering groups that help us kind of
distribute the product usually we are
part of a broader solution that they're
offering
sometimes a physical solution sometimes
um
development capabilities right like a
project that is and this is like a layer
in that
usually the heart of the system um but
what that helps us is surpass that kind
of uh um
the need to convince massive companies
that
not even us that this is the solution
that is the the the direction that they
should be even looking at um so kind of
going through massive players like those
that you know the end customer already
knows and trusts
makes our lives a lot easier
amazing it sounds like
you know beyond the under the
technological undertaking it's the
the true understanding of these
different use cases and being able to
generalize them internally being able to
to come up with a coherent strategy as
to how to to make it happen and and grow
this company and i love what you said
before
even before we started about the the
magnitude of what you're building here
and you know the the give behind the
moon shot but but if it works and
and and it sounds like it it is and you
know it's a it's a great undertaking for
you know for the economy and for
changing the
thought process that it's okay to have
different use cases and while
everybody's screaming okay move to the
cloud just deploy single serve
you know at the end there's complexities
and and different organizations need
different things with different
technologies and it sounds like ridge is
a is a fascinating journey and and i
really want to thank you for taking the
time to join me in sharing with me a
little bit about your strategy and about
how you're thinking through this world
and you're definitely making me go back
in a few years and think
how i'm looking at this this world of
cloud and and how it's being projected
to companies and what's going to happen
in the actual wave of cloud adoption
because we're just at the beginning and
and a lot of the players that that need
the solution that you're talking about
my i understand that why they may have
hesitations of
just transitioning to the current
solutions because
right now they're their on-premise
serves better than
than this generalized solution and so it
sounds like a really fascinating journey
and thank you mati very very much for
joining me
thank you very much
hey